hey everyone i'm jason and this is my
father karamo what
i'm joking hey friends i'm caramo from
netflix's queer eye and this is my son
jason rachel hi you guys
and today tasty has challenged us to
cook a dish
but we have no idea what that dish is
and i'm the one that's supposed to be
cooking it and i'm going to be the one
giving my dad the instructions with
these tasty cards but of course
this is tasty and we don't know how to
cook so there's a cast
always a catch there are some words that
are completely off limits right now
here are the rules of the game avoid
off-limit words
no miming while speaking and if any
rules are broken the instructor can only
mine
the next step that's a mess i mean
completely
because i have no idea actually not that
look at this
i think i do have an idea no no no no no
you have no idea what we're cooking down
i don't know
look at all this stuff right here listen
almost say is there some ingredients
over there that
i understand and as the father who
always cooked i i think i recognize
a couple of these things this is going
to be i don't i have no idea what this
is going to be
let's begin so here we are step one
blend together
egg there we
crack the egg go there beautiful now i'm
gonna need to grab that melted butter
now some flour um yes it's back here
i think i still know what this is now
that we're doing this back i don't think
you do that
it's okay you don't know granulated
sugar that's not brown sugar so that's
this one oh this is salt
are you sure positive i'm looking at it
that's salt that that looks like salt
that is salt you know what no one said
that we can't phone a friend let me call
anthony real quick
can we phone a friend i'm about to call
him and be like what does granulated
sugar look like oh this is sugar okay
okay good
and now we're gonna do milk here we go
perfect i feel like a pretty hot husband
right now here we go
pour in the milk and then the last thing
we're going to need some salt i feel
like we put in a lot of sweet stuff
and then we're going to dilute it with
some salt i i'm just so this is one of
the things that i
learned on queer eye after i make
somebody cry and i go in the kitchen to
eat some of anthony's food
and i always am like how are you mixing
sweetly salty and he's like
you need to do that because it gives
some type of flavor the word
is enhanced the more you know okay
there you go all right so that's all we
had to do for step one was you go
clockwork all we have to do
we got this okay let's not forget that
we have to blend this because
i don't know what that concoction would
be give us some power come on let's go
oh okay hey
so now we're going to go into step two
melt one and a half teaspoon
of so let's find the um oh now we go to
that let's do that real quick that's not
the the teaspoons though i know
these are not teaspoons all right okay
yes sir
half a teaspoon we are and now you're
going to be melting something right now
dad
let's look at all the items to see they
got to be butter you don't melt anything
else
you're a little too smart for me right
now i thought this is going to be
different you know what i think
i might already know what this is don't
get a little ahead of yourself right now
and we're gonna do it over a medium heat
until it is bubbling
so drop that in there is it on the
medium you know that line from double
wears prada was like
by all means move at a glacial pace you
know that i don't know that
this generation watch that movie okay
thank you people in this room know that
movie
how much are you guys in here oh snap
you said to put a teaspoon
you should have put a teaspoon of tea
you said to put a teaspoon
oh my goodness dad we are not doing this
[Music]
just a teaspoon step three here we come
we are going to pour a
half cup of let me figure this thing out
because i don't even think i see this
here
this is something that that comes before
making pancakes
you know oil okay no but you're on it's
a lick
it's a um i can't say that word gotta
buzz so now
this is this piece out of my mind to
work okay well i kind of already heard
so i know it's one of these
you don't know no you said you're
supposed to mind me please look at this
wasn't that a dance yeah i actually do
no i mean yeah
i'm doing something with my wrist it's
better
there you go great look at me
that's the batter this is the batter dad
so i do know you were gonna swirl it
around yeah i did the bottom of the pan
there i really hope we get this correct
yeah we are
half a cup of batter that's all right
that's going to be half a cup
i'm telling you i think we're doing
great do you think we're making crepes
yeah crepes are just thin really
really thin that's why we need a half a
cup and that's why we blended all that
stuff in there well that's gonna be a
really thick crepe if that's the case
well let's go to step four now we are
going to cook
um until set and it's uh so think of san
francisco what's the major landmark of
san francisco there you go and what is
that what is the name of that
golden gate bridge okay so that's the
first word
golden leave it at that what's our last
name golden brown
there we go until this is golden brown
it's uh it's
just golden brown and brown
hey hey cook it up till it's golden
brown
come on come on um i should have really
measured this
yeah i know so we're waiting for this to
be golden brown correct and spots on the
bottom
if someone was better at instructions i
would have known to measure
oh really they look like scrambled eggs
people at home
are going to appreciate the fact that
we're not professional cooks and
sometimes mistakes happen that's true
for life but when a mistake happens in
life you ask for help which is what
we're doing
we try to correct it as much as we can
and we just enjoy the journey
and that's what i'm doing i did not need
a dad moment right now
and then on that note let's move to step
five okay they're not going brown
but we're gonna it's gonna take some
time but we can still get the next step
while we're doing this i'm watching this
actually i'm probably gonna need a
spatula yes
you're like ahead of the game right now
well it's not that hard i know
ahead of the game is that your next clue
that's not my next clue okay what's your
clue
so here's the pot right mm-hmm
[Music]
you want me to oh my goodness so step
five
is flip and cook for another 30 to 60
seconds which i didn't even need to
explain to you because
you're so smart dad thanks son i
appreciate that
step six
picking up
are you squeezing something are you
pouring or something
dropping them right now i'm just
dropping you're supposed to be quiet i
didn't go to mime school excuse me you
guys
it's okay it's something that's like you
can take pieces off so that's going to
be either this
or this because everything else you
can't really take pieces of
okay are you sure so one of them is a
little too big
okay so this is too big yes but it was a
little too small
it's too small lovely and one of them is
just right
exactly beautiful there we go
are those not walnuts
these are walnuts myself and my son have
been on
several game shows as a family yeah we
have never won one
never i mean never i'm trying to get
this thing together we're getting closer
with this crepe
this is two steps to go dad but i'm
trying to salvage it okay
please show them what this scrape is
like nailed it
am i the one who's eating this yep you
are no this is just really really bad
toast walnuts in the pan and stir them
these are toasted as much as they're
gonna get toasted
okay step seven is remove from the pan
which you've already already done cause
i'm about it and this one says surprise
it's time to switch places about time
let's do this i know it seemed a little
bit difficult for my end but let's just
say this i'm not the best cook in this
arena but i have faith that you can do
this
how do you feel i feel good let's do
this you're about to do this all right
first in a pan melt butter until
you know when you're a little kid and
you have that thing that you dip in and
you blow
what comes out of it bubbles perfect in
a pan melt butter until it
is bubbling perfect there we go
so i just got informed uh-huh they said
that i did a slight mime
of i guess bubbles but it's fine so that
means that this next step
is going to fully be mined but it's okay
because this first step you did get
in a pan melt butter until bubbling okay
i have to mine this next step so just
follow me because i'm going to go step
by step and every time you get a word
i'm just going to do this
stirring
brown salt sugar
stirring the brown sugar
[Music]
and so it sounds like ear
no this is sounds like timing cinnamon
i tried i really did see that one you
can't mime
cinnamon that's like a very hard word to
mine
so you're gonna what's the first step
stirring the brown sugar and cinnamon
perfect great you're doing a really good
job by the way thank you
so you are you did a really good job
we're going to go on to step 10 as
you're doing that
so you're going to stir in this makes up
most of the earth water boom
and cook it until the sauce is darkened
and reduced the aroma is like so sweet
and
smells a little bit like christmas i'm
just going to say i got thanksgiving
vibes
thanksgiving works okay we're going to
step 11 now okay
all right you're going to be pouring in
liquid
adult drink rum so pour in the rum
and stir to combine okay you ready this
is for one minute so we're gonna go
through it
one one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand four four thousand five one
thousand six one thousand
seven point one eight one thousand nine
one dollars and ten nine sixty should
have been stirring that entire time but
it's okay
stir it a little bit now i'm just having
fun having fun with you dad this is step
twelve
we're gonna fold in something okay
this is something that monkeys
eat bananas so you're gonna fold in
the bananas and cook until softened turn
it back up now because we turned it down
before because you're assaulting a clue
and so now we can get some heat back on
there so you can start bubbling again
you can start folding in the bananas now
step 13 we're moving on to that as
you're doing this now we're going to be
placing
the crepe that i created on the opposite
of a bowl
a plate perfect but before we put that
very trifling and very tired
crate that i created on a plate
how about we try steps one through five
again with dad in the driver's seat and
see how you create a crate see if it's
better than this one
i'm almost sure it's gonna be better
than that because i have faith in here
go ahead and pour in
half a cup so find the half a cup first
here's africa right here okay great
of the batter awesome and i can tell
already that this is much hotter
and now what you're gonna do is you're
gonna swirl to coat the bottom so it's
just like you're going around
it's already looking much better than
mine though i'll tell you that much
father did not know what he was doing
but you have come in here and you are
doing an amazing job this crate is
looking great it is looking delicious
you're looking so lovely i'm loving
every bit of this okay
now you're going to be flipping it and
so when you flip it it should be nice
and thin so that way you have
a really nice crepe i mean we going
somewhere we're going somewhere look at
this this
this right here that looks like what it
was supposed to be like here's my crate
good job hold on can we do the side by
side this was dad's crate
this is sunscreen so now that we rewind
we're gonna come back okay here we go
okay this is step 14. you're gonna scoop
one and a half
cup of bananas onto the crepe
yes but specific spot the center
i didn't even have to say anything you
see yes that is correct you're putting
on the app that doesn't fall far from
the tree dad
yes good job this is step 15. you're
going to fold the edges of the crepe
inward to create this shape okay
oh i did say it you're right no no no i
didn't look down because i was going to
read the question i didn't go through
okay
i got to mine it yeah it's fine just
watch my hands okay
create the shape
a square there you go so you're gonna
fold the edges of the crepe inward to
create
a square there you go perfect now step
16
you're gonna top the crepe with pharrell
pharrell had a clothing
ice cream oh pop talk to a reference oh
god no reference hey all right there you
go perfect
and you're also going to do a little bit
of toasted walnuts awesome
this one the things that i do know to be
true because i walk like you know
tasty videos it's the presentation put a
little bit of the walnuts around the
plate
like just you know just in case the
crepe spills over when we're just going
in you can like have a little bit of the
walnut taste on the outside but a little
bit more
presentation okay there you go step 17
in our final step and i just got to say
good job generously there's a word
drake's
nickname is champagne there's other ones
it starts with the same letter as his
name drizzy drizzle
pop culture can help you in every stage
of life
and so you're just going to generously
drizzle drizzy drake
on the crepe yep there we go yeah just
put that sauce on there i didn't know we
were creating a crate
exactly but this is a banana foster
crate pocket and it looks like
extremely i mean we we outdid ourselves
right now i understand that was some
teamwork right there
son i'm really proud of you did a really
great job there we go thank you dad yeah
you followed you
really well but i would like to see how
far off we were so can we bring in what
it actually should look like
please let's see i mean
can we just be real this looks a little
dry we look a little juicy over here
okay
tasty i want to come and learn i ain't
going to shave y'all because this looks
really good yeah okay this looks really
good
but it looks real juicy and i am down to
try it
tell me how it tastes looking yummy
it's looking so good it's looking so
delicious
um son hold on
hold on i already know from your face
that thing is good
you did a good job feels good
i'm glad you like it yeah i'm gonna go
get my belt so you can start cooking for
me at home bye everybody
okay and i guess that's just how you're
gonna leave me out here then huh no i'll
come back in
listen this is really good hope you
enjoyed watching us
figure out what we're gonna cook and
actually learning how to communicate
because i think we have really good
communities we do but that actually just
a little bit
exposed me for a little bit but it's all
right listen if you want to learn more
go ahead swipe up watch like this video
do all of that
because this was tasty do you want to
make this dish
and there's many others now i'm about to
really go bye thank you guys
oh yes
[Music]
bye